[Música]
jornada electoral en Turquía con
resultados todavía provisionales no hay
nuevo presidente electo en esta edición
analizamos las relaciones entre el
estado Turco y América Latina marcadas
por el acercamiento con Venezuela
crisis en la tercera Ronda de diálogos
entre el estado colombiano y la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional el grupo armado acusa al
presidente Gustavo Petro de
estigmatizarlos al relacionarlos con
economías ilícitas
en Bolivia país que forma parte del
llamado Triángulo del litio este mineral
llega a nuevos ámbitos de la vida
cotidiana particularmente a través de la
Industria Del automóvil en La Paz los
vehículos eléctricos son un nuevo
elemento del sistema de salud
Bienvenidos a esta edición informativa
centrada en las noticias más relevantes
del continente americano soy Rosa Pérez
masdeu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles Y empezamos esta edición
con información relacionada con Turquía
porque allí tras un largo y ajustado
conteo Y todavía según los resultados
provisionales en el escenario actual el
país no tiene nuevo presidente electo
estos comicios se han presentado como
cruciales no solo en clave interna sino
también internacionalmente ahora para
acercarnos el análisis América Latina
nos acompaña en el estudio Luis Muñoz
bienvenido un gusto acompañar la rosa
Luis ankara tiene un socio prioritario
aquí en la región y es Venezuela no de
qué se trata
Rosa el 9 de julio de 2018 fue la
investidura del presidente erdogan Solo
hubo un invitado latinoamericano
Venezuela con su presidente Nicolás
Maduro relaciones que han ido creciendo
y están actualmente en su momento cumbre
de hecho a principios de 2023 el
canciller venezolano Iván Gil dijo que
las relaciones están en su máximo nivel
en este momento el intercambio comercial
se sitúa alrededor de los mil millones
de dólares solo con acuerdos en 40 áreas
especialmente destacables es el vínculo
en cuestiones del Oro tras las sanciones
Venezuela dejó de refinar oro en Suiza y
pasó a Turquía una alternativa económica
al bloqueo de su petróleo en la cuestión
política Cabe destacar que erdogan no
reconoció a Juan guaidó como presidente
interino de Venezuela y el pasado año
tras la invasión de Rusia Ucrania el
canciller aseguró que el mundo entero
necesita el petróleo y el gas natural de
Venezuela Rosa estas serían las
relaciones entre erdogan y maduro pero
cuáles son serían las de quilishroglu
recordemos que aquí les daré
a occidente y querría de distanciarse de
Vladimir Putin uno de los socios de
Venezuela sin embargo rebuscando en la
hemeroteca nos encontramos el siguiente
tuit
creemos firmemente que Venezuela seguirá
ascendiendo y desarrollándose a partir
del camino abierto por Chávez
estos fueron sus palabras tras la muerte
de Chávez por lo que alejarse de las
posturas de orogán no implicaría que
pudiera perder el camino emprendido en
las relaciones entre Turquía y Venezuela
sin embargo en plena campaña la semana
pasada hubo un pequeño escándalo el
ministro de agricultura se fue de visita
a Venezuela y queréis darle luz dijo que
en Turquía tienen muy buena agricultura
y que eso no es necesario y dejó una
pregunta al aire Rosa van a Venezuela
por otra razón ellos lo saben Luis
Muchas gracias a por este repaso por
acercarnos las relaciones entre Turquía
y la región latinoamericana
particularmente con Venezuela un gusto
nosotros seguimos esta edición con más
información de la región Y es que
Colombia está en plena tercera Ronda de
negociaciones con la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional esta vez
los diálogos son en la Habana Cuba y han
vuelto a entrar en crisis después de que
el presidente Gustavo Petro dijese que
las bases del el están dedicadas a las
economías ilícitas cada mesa de
negociación entre la guerrilla del
ejército de liberación nacional y el
gobierno colombiano tiene su crisis para
la actual ronda en Cuba el detonante
unas palabras del presidente Gustavo
Petro que el eln consideró de
estigmatizantes el viernes frente su
cúpula militar Petro dijo que los
negociadores no mandan sobre los
guerrilleros jóvenes dedicados a las
economías ilícitas Antonio García
comandante del eln tuiteó lo siguiente
este domingo las declaraciones del
presidente Petro son delicadas habrá un
pronunciamiento del Comando central el
camino hacia la Paz es un asunto serio
en la guerrilla están indignados con las
palabras de Petro después de que en la
segunda Ronda de conversaciones en
México el equipo negociador reconociese
el carácter político de la organización
no entienden Este cambio en su retórica
sin embargo el sábado el presidente de
Colombia volvió a hablar sobre las
negociaciones bajando el tono e hizo una
propuesta y que podemos comenzar
no idea nacional como lo propuse en
diciembre compleja difícil muy inestable
muy peligrosa
sino en la idea territorial regional
porque indudablemente la paz de Colombia
hoy es más que nada una paz territorial
Petro tiene prisa por avanzar en las
negociaciones puesto que va a cumplir
pronto su primer año en la presidencia
las declaraciones son vistas como una
forma de presionar para conseguir un
alto el fuego con la guerrilla activa
más antigua de América Latina
y cambiamos de información porque
Ecuador vive una de las situaciones de
seguridad más complejas de la región las
costas de Guayaquil se convirtieron en
uno de los principales puertos de
exportación de drogas de América Latina
y la fuerza pública intenta mantener el
control territorial frente a los grupos
armados mientras la población vive
atemorizada
es el golfo de Guayaquil uno de los
principales puntos de exportación de
cocaína del mundo Este es un operativo
de la marina ecuatoriana una inspección
rutinaria
hacer que su embarcación desde 2021 la
policía decomisado cerca de 500
toneladas de drogas en registros como
este y en algún tiene algo
algún objeto contundente con la pulsante
Ecuador al estar entre Perú y Colombia
los mayores productores de cocaína se ha
convertido en un lugar clave para el
narcotráfico los homicidios
prácticamente se duplicaron entre 2021 y
2022 este golfo es complicado de
contener porque les da la facilidad de
la salida al mar para realizar
sus actividades ilícitas es fácilmente
para ellos llegar a
estas vías a estos accesos de los brazos
del mar del Golfo
pero los grupos criminales no solo
atemorizan a las fuerzas de seguridad
también a Los Pescadores que viven en la
zona les cobran alrededor de 30 dólares
a la semana para trabajar extorsiones y
robos la familia de Hilda Vera hace
Guardia nocturna hace poco les quitaron
un motor todo da miedo Oiga salir a
pescar como salir a cangrejal para todo
da miedo
la solución del gobierno ha sido
decretar varios estados de excepción e
incluso el porte de armas de defensa
personal Aunque bajo requisitos
estrictos sin embargo el miedo no cesa
en la ciudad de la paz en Bolivia los
médicos pueden ahora desplazarse en
pequeños carros eléctricos para ir a
visitar a los pacientes que viven lejos
del centro en este país Rico en litio
una materia que permite la fabricación
de vehículos eléctricos se sueña con una
economía impulsada por este material
Gabriel colchen nos cuenta más
el Doctor Carlos Ortuño se sube a un
pequeño carro eléctrico para ir a
visitar a una de sus pacientes en las
afueras de la paz el programa llamado
médicos en tu casa hace parte de una
estrategia del gobierno para acercar los
médicos a los pacientes que viven lejos
del centro de la ciudad y para eso se
les propone el uso de estos pequeños
carritos eléctricos es un gran sistema
moderno ecológico y bueno también la
tenemos que acostumbrar a la a la
sociedad paceña que a quien no conozca
el auto y pues nos nos colabore también
no la circulación el vehículo se mueve a
56 kilómetros por hora y puede recorrer
80 kilómetros antes de ser cargado en un
enchufe doméstico la empresa que los
produce cree que puede transformar la
Industria automovilística del país la
electromovilidad en todo el mundo va a
reinar muy pronto pero va a formas
diferentes
en Estados Unidos será tesla y ese tipo
de autos de alta velocidad mayor
autonomía etcétera Pero creemos que
latinoamérica la mayoría de los autos
van a ser de menor autonomía y más
compactos por qué Porque nuestras calles
así lo demandan en los últimos años se
ha disparado la demanda por el litio
también llamado oro blanco indispensable
para la fabricación de baterías de
vehículos eléctricos y de celulares en
Bolivia chile y Argentina podrían estar
el 85% de sus reservas mundiales sin
embargo la extracción de litio ha sido
críticada por las grandes cantidades de
agua que requiere
gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]